the opening scene features Heaven
incorporation a business-like
infrastructure that controls how Earth
should operate the infrastructure is run
by the CEO God who is currently watching
TV to keep tabs on the many horrible
things happening on Earth such as
melting ice caps deadly forest fires and
so on he seems to have no interest in
any of this news but is drawn to a
broadcast of NASCAR drivers who thank
God for their victories due to his
disheveled appearance and lack of
productivity his right-hand man sanj is
quick to dismiss any important meetings
such as the one focused on ending all
pain on Earth the scene then cuts to the
Department of Angel resources where a
young woman Eliza Hunter is being
transferred out of her current role in
the department of dirt to a new job in
the department of answered prayers she
excitedly marches straight to her new
department where she meets Craig who's
been working their solo for thousands of
years it appears that he answers the
easy easiest prayers possible and sends
the on stamped impossible to God who
ignores it as usual as they're too hard
to resolve after introducing themselves
Craig briefs her on the rules they
should follow while answering people's
prayers they can't act beyond the laws
of nature regardless while Craig goes
out to answer more wish lists Eliza
answers a farmer's prayer for rain
unintentionally triggering a typhoon and
endangering several lives of the
earthlings sensing the urgency Eliza
goes to God God's chamber and asks him
to help out the people on Earth God
seems to be so bored and fed up that he
decides to blow up the entire planet and
to move on to other projects this
announcement sets all the employees into
a panic while the department of Angel
resources starts referring their people
to other galaxies Eliza who is against
this plan confronts God questioning why
he's doing so he argues that prayers are
so vague that it's impossible to fulfill
in response Eliza proposes a bet if
she's able to answer one of the
impossible prayers God spares Earth he
agrees on the condition that if she
fails to do so within 2 weeks she'll
have to eat a worm following this she
goes to explain her new assignment to
Craig and invites him to discuss it over
some burgers Craig thrilled to have a
companion after Years of Solitude agrees
right away together they go through
numerous impossible stamped prayers in
an attempt to choose the easiest one not
long after after they come across a
prayer of a boy and a girl both of whom
like each other but are unable to
confess as a result Eliza and Craig
decide to fulfill their wish to be
together in the next scene God is
watching an interview featuring an
atheist bill Mayer Who is making
misleading statements against religious
beliefs as a result God instructs Sanjay
to eliminate bill right away with no
other choice Sanjay agrees and discusses
the ways to kill him to which God
instructs him to blow up Bill's penis
following this Sanjay goes to the
Department of genitals and orders the
employees to blow up Bill's organ
despite being confused at first the
employees agree to carry out the order
back in the department of answered
prayers Eliza and Craig are in the
process of digging out more information
about the boy and girl Sam and Laura
they soon figure out that the two of
them are 98% compatible as they share
the same likes and dislikes they both
share pollen allergies and love year
but unfortunately they are antisocial in
nature due to which they haven't
communicated with each other since the
night they met this makes Eliza realize
that a bold divine intervention is
needed to get the pair to meet again
meanwhile the employees in the genitals
Department unintentionally make Bill's
organ more attractive which frustrates
God Sanjay then decides to take the
matter into his own hands however it's
not that easy because he must pump a
machine 50,000 times to blow up Bill's
package despite this setback Sanjay
somehow manages to complete the process
finally killing bill it's not quite as
good as Tarantino's rendition but it is
funnier on the other hand Eliza comes up
with a plan to injure both Sam and Laura
leading them to meet in the same
hospital however Craig is hesitant to
carry out such a risky plan and suggests
that they find some other way out Eliza
angered by Craig's reluctance labels him
a coward and sto STS off he soon
realizes his mistake and follows her to
apologize eventually reaching a
compromise the duo then devises another
plan and somehow managed to bring Laura
and Sam to a common restaurant under the
pretense of Euros their plan seems to
have worked out as the pair ultimately
exchanges phone numbers from the very
next day the two start texting each
other things appear great until Laura
accidentally bumps into a dashing
stranger Mason in a coffee shop that
spins into into instant attraction they
soon start conversing which sets Eliza
and Craig into a panic the two Bond so
quickly that Mason takes her to a date
after convincing her to skip work during
their outing in the park Craig and Eliza
attempt to sabotage their date by
triggering a strong rainstorm however
the rain makes mason even more handsome
creating a romantic atmosphere in the
meantime sanj is being interviewed by
some TV reporters called Game Changers
where he boasts about his past
accomplishments in the midst of the
interview Sanjay is summoned by the
spoon feeding God to help him operate a
microwave oven Sanjay quickly teaches
him the techniques and then returns to
the news reporters simultaneously God
continues to make Havoc for himself he
burns his hands and again calls Sanjay
to spoon feed him at this point in time
the news reporter enters God's office
and sees Sanjay doing the small chores
undermining His Image later that day
Craig and Eliza are failing miserably on
their mission so they decide to seek
help from sanj the two approach him in
his cabin only to find him sobbing due
to the earlier embarrassment upon
learning about the incident they managed
to encourage Sanjay to prove his
strength convincing him to help them
after this the trio start working on
thwarting the developing relationship
between Mason and Laura at first they
figure out that Mason's father owns a
large Oil Company after which they
destroy his oil ship causing him to go
bankrupt as a consequence Mason's father
cuts off his pocket money which makes
him so mad that he uses curse words
seeing his true colors Laura finally
loses her interest in him she then
returns home and texts Sam bringing a
smile to the latter's face in the
aftermath Sanjay sees the case as
beneficial for his career and chooses to
continue working on it rather than
returning to God Craig is disappointed
as he feels replaced in his duties as
days pass by Eliza and Sanjay start
working together on their mission while
Craig feels like left out one day Sanjay
shares details about his past life with
colleagues revealing that he was the
leader of a historic Empire Eliza in
turn discloses that she had been a
fierce Nordic Warrior who successfully
overthrew an oppressive King from her
country the duo then press Craig to
reveal about his past to which he
hesitantly does showing that he was
nothing more than a caveman he sadly
admits that he is not as cool as them
now that Sanjay is working in the
department of answered prayers another
secretary named Rosie has to deal with
God's annoying Behavior unable to
tolerate him Rosie suggests that he talk
to someone from Earth she even chooses a
guy named Dave an eye surgeon who also
plays guitar in a band on the weekends
God then uses his microphone to talk to
Dave who is initially frightened by the
experience in the interim Rosie goes
back to Sanjay and asks him to come back
as she can't handle God however the
latter refuses so Craig who seems to
have started to feel alone again decides
to volunteer to be God's new wingman
upon entering God's chamber Craig sees
him singing for Dave but Dave on the
other side goes to see a psychiatrist
thinking that he's gone crazy God then
orders Craig to hit Dave with a tornado
so that the doctor can know about his
true nature when the tornado destroys
his house Dave finally confronts God and
politely requests him to leave him alone
to which he unexpectedly agrees amidst
all this Sanjay manages to have Sam and
Laura meet at a party through a m ual
friend as the pair awkwardly Converse
sanj enhances their romance with some
alcohol unfortunately the dose becomes
too much for them as they begin to feel
dizzy unable to figure out their next
step Sanjay goes to get Craig back to
help solve the issue following this
Craig rushes down to his former
department and learns that the situation
is about to get worse to prevent the
pair from drinking further he uses his
divine intervention to make the pair
leave the party as they walk back home
they finally plan to go on a date on
Friday Eliza and Sanjay are relieved by
this and praise Craig's performance
making him feel good however their Joy
is shortlived as they learn that Sam's
lovely grandma has less than 3 hours to
live fearing that Sam might cancel his
date due to his grandmother's imminent
death Sanjay suggests that they visit
the department of death to keep her
alive heeding to his advice the trio
heads there and requests that the
Department's supervisor give her a life
extension in return the supervisor hands
them a dead waiver form asking them to
have it signed by God after which the
Granny's life will be extended by 100
Days with no alternative the three Rush
upstairs and seek Rosy's assistance for
the same however Rosie seems to have
grown so unsatisfied with her current
work that she's actually waiting for the
earth to explode amidst their
conversation she accidentally mentions
that God is illiterate this Revelation
strikes Eliza with an idea and she
decides to trick God in into signing the
form hearing this strategy Craig is
overwhelmed with nervousness but the
other two team members tell him to stay
calm the trio then enters God's chamber
and presents the form claiming it's a
liquor license document tension fills
the air as God reviews the form most of
its effect is seen on Craig much to
their relief God agrees to sign it
confirming that he can't read but just
before signing it Rosie enters and
insists that she read the document first
while God steps away for a moment Eliza
tries to persuade Rosie to continue
working for heaven and help them in
Saving Earth she also emphasizes her
significance in the team as she's the
most talented employee here this
convinces Rosie who then confirms the
death waiver form as a licensing form
after obtaining God's signature they
immediately submit the form in the death
Department successfully extending the
Granny's life in the aftermath Rose
officially joins the team and is happy
to finally have a meaningful job with
only 14 hours left before the Earth's
imminent explosion the team closely
monitors Sam and Laura not long after
they learn that the pair is planning to
go to a movie theater to watch a
documentary on the sewer system
realizing that it won't contribute to
their romantic connection the team makes
a divine intervention by blowing up the
entire theater before they reach it with
the movie date cancelled the two opt to
watch a basketball game instead
meanwhile God visits his parents' place
to present his new project to them
hoping to get some startup funding for
it upon arrival he notices that his
siblings are also present there later
while having their meal the parents ask
their children about their respective
planets in response God's siblings
explain the perfect state of their
planets while God is hesitant to talk
about his creation Earth instead he
changes the topic and proceeds to pitch
his new project building a space
restaurant with the name lazy Susans the
parents are clearly uninterested in this
as they feel that he will waste their
money just like he did with Earth
furthermore they confront him about the
types of living beings that he created
on his Planet especially humans with
free will God tries to defend himself
stating that he just wanted to provide
freedom and happiness to his people
later in the day Sam and Laura arrive at
the basketball court for their date
seemingly excited for their long awaited
date they quickly start to bond over
their shared lack of knowledge about
basketball to enhance the Romantic
atmosphere the team decides to set a
kiss cam on the two of them hoping that
they will kiss kiss each other Craig is
completely against this idea and claims
that it's too much intervention and
won't work out when the team refuses to
comply he tries to physically dismantle
the computer system this forces the team
to carry him to a closet and lock him
inside after this they Pan the kiss cam
onto the pair leaving them extremely
nervous soon after a mascot approaches
them which only intensifies their
embarrassment seeing this Eliza reacts
quickly and bursts the mascots aend iend
causing him to collapse on the floor
upon witnessing this the entire crowd
begins to accuse Sam and Laura of
killing the mascot prompting them to
leave the scene once outside Sam feels
that she's disturbed by the incident and
asks if she wants to go home Laura
misunderstands this and thinks that he
doesn't want to continue the date any
longer as a result an argument ensues
between the two causing them to depart
angrily now that their plan is failed
and there's no more time to save Earth
the team gives up and apologizes to
Craig admitting that he was right on the
other hand God has seen arguing with his
parents and siblings about his planet
Earth at one point he has a change of
heart and decides not to destroy his
creation because he is happy with what
he's doing he then returns back to
Heaven incorporation and heads straight
to the Department of answered prayers
however there's a problem now the
explosion process can't be reversed as
he was the one to finalize it earlier
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching